From a secret hot Invisible Man to monstrous
adult jokes, Hotel Transylvania 4 is packed
with hilarious¬ references and easter eggs
you might have missed.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video I'm revealing 27 deliciously
dark details and hidden gags the filmmakers
snuck into the movie.
Some spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
The movie begins with the hotel's 125th Anniversary
party and a spectacular array of monster performances
organised by Johnny, including the Werewolf
Kids running out on stage with a set of cards
that spell out "Happy Anniversary".
But in their mad rush, the pups trip and tumble
over each other and as they get up their cards
now read:
Very phine a…
Ooh, oh no!
The scene quickly moves on, but although it
looks like the name Phineas, there's a crucial
gap so that P, H, I, N and E is pronounced
"fine" and that last S card was going to complete
the end of another word.
You can see the joke in full for just the
tiniest fraction of a second later when Drac
freezes the chaos at the party before he quickly
rearranges the letters to read "Happy Anniversary".
There are some devilishly dark and gruesome
little details you might have easily overlooked
at the party dinner tables.
There's the centrepiece which is not only
made up of flowers, but also tentacles and
eyeballs.
Instead of ordinary forks and knives, the
guests have mini axes and prongs to eat with,
and then there's the salt and pepper pots
whose design appears to be inspired by the
infamous iron maiden torture devices given
the little spikes on top and the anguished
faces.
When Van Helsing takes Johnny down into his
lab to show him the Monster-fication Ray,
you can spot a ton of weird and wonderful
objects from the former villain's monster-hunting
days,
including a huge dinosaur skeleton, a mysterious
humanoid skeleton with horns, a giant robot
outfit, and an old diving suit he might have
used to discover the ancient underwater civilization
of Atlantis.
And hanging from the ceiling is a replica
of the aeroplane he used when hunting Drac
in Hotel Transylvania 3.
Also, there appears to be the body of a giant
shark, which could be what happened to Sharkie,
one of the monster pets Drac introduced to
Tinkles in the short film Monster Pets!
Sharkie!
When Van Helsing uses the Monster-fication
Ray on Gigi the gerbil and then on Johnny,
right next to him is a giant circular stone
with an engraving of a tentacled monster,
a secret reference to the Kraken that Van
Helsing hypnotised and used to attack Drac
and the other monsters in Hotel Transylvania
3.
And just like he converted the friendly Kraken
into an angry beast with the Instrument of
Destruction in that movie, in Hotel Transylvania
4 Van Helsing's contraption also slowly turns
Johnny into a raging uncontrollable monster.
And the central part of the stone with the
face and surrounding wave pattern is the secret
entrance to the ruins of Atlantis from the
third film.
It's probably no coincidence either that there's
a portrait of one of Van Helsing's ancestors
from the third movie just outside the elevator
door at the hotel looking on as Drac accidentally
turns himself into a human with the Monster-fication
Ray.
Drac tries to hide his transformation from
Mavis, and the other monsters help by distracting
her with Wayne's new dance moves.
The routine he tries to do is inspired by
real-life social media dance challenges, in
particular the viral hit "Renegade" dance
created by Jalailah Harmon.
Oh, yeah.
And speaking of social media stars, the character
of Party Monster is played by streamer "Ninja",
aka Tyler Blevins.
Oh yeah.
When Griffin becomes human, the Drac Pack
is shocked to learn that he's been naked from
the moment we first met him, a little hat-tip
to the fans of the franchise who guessed this
early on:
Have you seriously been naked this whole time?
Uh, yeah.
Why would only my glasses be visible?
Notice how he has red curly hair as he explained
in the first movie.
What's wrong with red, curly hair?
Why are you getting upset?
I have red curly hair!
Now, Griffin's human form as a balding, pot-bellied,
middle-aged man caused a bit of a stir among
some Hotel Transylvania fans when the movie's
trailer came out.
Over 30,000 people signed a petition on behalf
of "The Invisible Man Simps Community" asking
Sony Animation to make Griffin hot.
And it's possible the filmmakers give a little
nod to this because they actually snuck an
alternate version of Griffin into the final
movie.
To catch this, watch really carefully during
the crystal cave scene because as broken reflections
of each character appear in the giant crystals,
when Griffin wanders into view, in the corner
there's a design of him that's completely
different including a full head of hair.
I'm inviz.
Man, just because you're invisible doesn't
mean you get to be naked.
Gremlin Air makes a hilarious return for the
fourth movie and there's a bit of humorous
lampshading that acknowledges how ridiculous
it is that the plane can actually fly.
How is this plane even in the sky?!
Is that duct tape holding the wing together?!
After arriving in South America, Johnny and
Drac take a bus to the Amazon but when Johnny's
monster size slows it down, he decides to
move the vehicle along by picking it up and
running with it,
a shout-out to the old school animation The
Flintstones where Fred and his friend Barney
would sometimes use foot power to literally
run their car.
There's a long-running joke in the franchise
that Drac supposedly goes around saying " bleh,
bleh-bleh".
Yes, fellow Dracula.
There's only one way.
Bleh, bleh-bleh.
I don't know where that comes from.
And it's true that according to Vampires.com,
Dracula has never said the phrase either in
the books or the live-action movies that came
before the animated movie franchise.
However, in Hotel Transylvania 4, as Drac
tries to explain why he made up the monster
real estate law, he says...
Johnny found out that I was giving you guys
the hotel.
But then he
had a Johnny takeover:
escalators, name changes, blah, blah, blah.
Although Ericka gave up her monster-hunting
ways at the end of the third movie, when she
goes in search of Drac and Johnny, she gets
some of her old monster-hunting contraptions
out again.
There's her blimp which is full of lethal
weapons,
Okay.
Yeah, it's a death trap.
and the tank-like armoured vehicle she drives
has a license plate that reads "MNSTR HNTR".
The jeep also has a V-shaped ornament as a
nod to her family name, just like the car
her great granddaddy chased Drac with.
When the gang eventually arrive at the Crystal
Cave, they enter through an opening that looks
like the jaws of a monster.
And when the cave begins to collapse later
on, as Frank and Eunice run from the falling
rocks they both say
If he ruins my hair, I'm never gonna forgive
him!
That's a funny call-back to the third movie
where Eunice was playing volleyball and was
worried about getting her hair wet.
Everybody, just please watch the hair.
Watch the hair!
And the way the gang shield Mavis from the
sun's rays at the end of the movie, as she
runs to reach Johnny and turn him back into
a human, is a neat parallel to how Drac was
shielded from the sun as he raced to reach
Johnny at the end of the first movie.
Don't worry we got you covered.
The way the wolf pups extend in a line to
provide shade for Mavis is similar to how
the townspeople formed a line to cover Drac
in the original film.
And something you might not have noticed is
that the voice of Drac changed for this fourth
film from Adam Sandler who played him in the
first three movies to voice actor, impressionist,
and YouTuber Brian Hull.
Hull already voiced Drac in the short film
Monster Pets and does an excellent job in
the new feature sounding uncannily like Sandler's
Drac.
Thank you Johnny.
How wonderful.
So, what did you think of the fourth and final
Hotel Transylvania movie and how it ended?
And who are your favourite characters?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this video then do hit that
like button, I really appreciate it.
And tap left if you'd like to discover all
the easter eggs and everything you missed
in Disney's Encanto and more animated movies.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!